i don't know what mitch mcconnell
personally thinks about abortion but if
this goes through if the if the
roe v wade is overruled he deserves a
whole lot of credit and then as he's
saying now if there if there were a
national abortion law
the guy would be one of the great heroes
of pre-born babies in the history of the
world
this guy would be one of the truly one
of the greatest statesmen
in history
and it could happen another reason why
this is important too for republicans to
get behind this kind of talk is
it it will allow
in a very cynical way it will allow
republicans to continue to raise money
off of all of us pro-lifers
one of the
issues with the pro-life movement for
the past 50 years with regard to the
republican party is that the republicans
relied on pro-lifers to give them a lot
of money to get rid of abortion but the
problem there of course is if roe v wade
is overruled the republicans feared that
they would lose the money from the
pro-lifers because the problem would
have gone away and so there was a kind
of a perverse incentive there for the
republicans not to really fight that
hard against abortion because they were
making so much money from the pro-lifers
but as we have said on this show many
times
roe v wade is not the end of the story
you overrule roe v wade that's not the
end of the fight that's really just the
beginning of the fight because the fight
here is not just for some procedural
aspect of our judiciary or some
interesting reading of the text of the
constitution and some long lecture about
federalism the point is to protect
babies and so i don't want there to be
abortion in california i don't want
there to be abortion in new york i do
not respect the right so-called of new
yorkers or californians to have abortion
i think it's wrong all the time
everywhere it's just wrong to kill
babies and so the pro-life fight is
going to have to continue there whether
that's by fighting for laws in the
states or whether that's fighting for a
federal law so we'll this will allow
republicans to continue to raise money
off of all of us pro-lifers and it's
going to give us another place to look
after roe v wade becomes
history
why is cocaine mitch going after this as
well
one i think it's the right thing to do
i'll give him credit for it two i think
it's obviously the next step in this
movement but three it's a political
winner it's a big political winner it's
not just some niche issue for extremely
far-right conservatives pro-life is a
winning message for americans period
full stop bill maher just proved my
point i've been on this hobby horse for
a very long time and i've been i've been
shouting it from the rooftops bill maher
just proved my point when when on his
show he said he didn't want to talk
about abortion but you know this is the
big topic this week and so he was going
to talk about it and he said you know by
golly
i had i had no idea a lot of the things
i thought i knew about abortion turns
out they were just totally false
you know it's interesting because until
this memo was leaked and we found out
that now unless something we very
unforeseen happens the supreme court is
going to
undo roe versus wade after 49 years we
haven't really been focusing on it or
maybe i'm projecting i guess i haven't
been enough because i learned things
this week because this put it on the
front page that are pretty basic things
that i did not know
about abortion
like in europe
the modern countries of europe
way more restrictive than we are or what
they're even proposing if you are
pro-choice
you would like it a lot less in germany
and italy and france and spain and
switzerland did you know that i didn't
know that i didn't know that that's
right okay
um i learned most people who are
pro-life are women
did not know that
did you know that yes you probably did
if you're listening to this show you
probably pay
a little more attention to politics than
most people do and you probably know a
little bit more of the arguments and you
probably know a little bit more of the
facts
i suspect most americans are like bill
maher though
i suspect most americans
don't pay extraordinarily close
attention and so they don't realize yeah
most pro-lifers are women they don't
realize what the abortion laws are in
france and germany and italy and
pretty much everywhere else around the
world
more restrictive than they are in the
united
it's not their fault states that they
don't know they have been inundated with
propaganda lies from
hollywood from the press from
the educational institutions
and so they it's it's not even that
they're ignorant as ronald reagan said
it's just that they know so many things
that are not so
now that we're beginning to crack that
monopoly on information
now that we're beginning to just get the
reality of abortion out there
it's a huge political winner people see
the reality of what abortion is
and they just don't like it i'm so glad
you like that clip now
ring that smash that bell ring that like
click that subscribe make sure you get
all the notifications
also head on over to apple podcast
spotify stitcher google play wherever
you get your audio podcast for free can
you imagine and get the michael knowles
show leave a five star review we will
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you